yo yo what's up internet people this is
dr john delony with ramsey network
today we are talking about chemical
imbalances anxiety
and when should we take medication for
anxiety would that
fix us okay so i'm responding to an
email i got at ash john
ramseysolutions.com by the way i'm
getting emails from all over the country
tons of them keep them coming they're so
good and we're about to launch the john
dalone show in the next couple of months
so keep them coming i'm loving it okay
so this email is from
andrew hey dr d what's up i've heard
that anxiety can be caused by a chemical
imbalance in your body
is this true and does this require
medication to balance out
or will things like box breathing and
journaling help
long term to balance me out i have
extreme anxiety and it's only getting
worse
respectfully andrew number one
big time shout out to andrew for being
vulnerable being
open thank you for your note i'm getting
this question from
everybody i get it from my family
members from my co-workers from people i
meet in the grocery store
not really and especially from emails
so here's my thoughts on medication on
anxiety
and chemical imbalances is anxiety
caused by chemical imbalance in our
brain
i want to back away from that question
because i really don't like
the way that questions posed the short
answer is yes
all of our actions are electronic and
magnetic
and chemical based everything we do
going to the bathroom it's a chemical
imbalance um
being attracted to somebody it's a
chemical imbalance being angry it's a
chemical imbalance
feeling hungry it's a chemical
everything's a chemical imbalance
and so we often hear the word chemical
imbalance and we think
i'm broken and what needs to be fixed
is the chemical level in my head i'm
going to go with somebody and get an
external chemical and it's going to fix
my internal problem
it's going to level me out and all is
going to be well
it's not really how it works and we
could go into all the biochemistry and
all the hormones and all of the
histories and all the stuff
but instead i'm going to answer that
question pretty simply in a few short
steps
first i love how brene brown says it
genetics loads the gun
and environment pulls the trigger when
it comes to your psychology into your
brain chemistry
who you are genetically chemically
plays a role in the world you grew up in
also plays a role and you're not a
static robot your
genome your genes don't make you who
you're going to be
your genes can be turned on and off and
expressed and
unexpressed and muted because of all
sorts of different things
from the air you breathe the
relationships you have the relationships
you didn't have
trauma good nutrition all sorts of
different things
i also love the phrase that we throw
around in counseling a lot which is your
childhood biography becomes your adult
biology how much adrenaline and cortisol
were flowing through your veins as a kid
when you were trying to protect yourself
from
trauma when you're trying to connect
with a parent who is too busy texting
all of those things turn into your adult
wiring and the third thing is we can
control our thoughts
and our actions we can control
what we think about all the time and
it's hard and it's challenging
and depending on our genetic wiring and
depending on
some of our life histories depending on
some of the things that have happened to
us
our addictions our coping mechanisms the
things we do when we want to numb or
hide
controlling our thoughts is really hard
or when you're locked in your house for
five months because the world's shut
down because of some invisible virus
or you get laid off or you found out she
cheated on you again
or your grandmother passes away all
those things set off
different fire alarms and that's why i
say often anxiety is just a fire alarm
is it chemical yeah but it's
so much more than that so the question
andrew asks here is
does it require medication to fix
anxiety
the answer is usually no usually no
usually with the right relationships the
right exercise and nutrition program
the right meditating journaling
breathing being
present program which we call
life anxiety just is a normal ebb and
flow in your life
there are times like he mentions here he
has extreme anxiety
when i got laid low by anxiety just
wiped out
i spent a couple of years taking anxiety
medication and what
it does is it just silences the alarms
it's like going out to the back of your
house back behind the garage with a pair
of hedge clippers
where the electricity is coming in and
you just turn the power off to the
alarms
it just shuts them off it doesn't fix
you
it just shuts them off but when my
alarms were finally
quiet then i got to do the hard work of
uncovering childhood traumas
reforming and remaking relationships
learning how to journal learning how to
sit with a counselor
learning how to get to know myself for
the first time so in my world
they were really helpful for a short
period of time and i worked specifically
with a doctor
and when i met with my doctor for the
first time i said i will not put a pill
in my mouth until i have an exit
strategy
and we worked together to make sure that
worked out
and i'm happy to say i haven't taken
medication in years and years and years
and my anxiety alarms will go off
because they should
because it's a healthy important part of
our lives
but i also know when they're about to
take off when they're about to head for
the hills
when they're about to really start going
and i've got enough tools like box
breathing i've got enough tools like
calling a friend i've got enough tools
like
a community that's my emergency fund for
life
my spirituality my daily practices
my nutrition my exercise things that i
do on a regular basis
that keep the alarms from getting out of
control so if you're suffering from
extreme anxiety andrew
go talk to somebody you know you better
than anybody
and when you feel alone and you feel
like everyone around you is crazy
and when every time you open your eyes
your heart starts beating
and all you're doing is scrolling
through looking for the next
worst thing you will find the next worst
thing
that's the demon of anxiety so go find a
counselor
go find somebody to talk to and see if
medication is right for you go talk to a
doctor
i hope this helps andrew if you or
anybody else has
more questions about brain chemistry
anxiety depression
how that all works and you all want to
take a super deep dive hit me up at ask
john
ramseysolutions.com otherwise i will see
you soon
take care be kind to one another go
exercise eat good
and get a good night's sleep take care